Wolfgang, du hast ein Buch vorgeschlagen.
Ja.
Es stellt sich heraus, es basiert auf zwei Gutachten für den Bundestag. Also sehr hochspezifische Kommunikation, bei der man jetzt keine Worte auf Literatizität oder wie das heißt, verschwendet.
Ist kein Schmöker.
Sondern man geht direkt rein.
Ja. Öffentliche Kunstfreiheit heißt das Buch von Christoph Möllers und Nils Weinberg. Christoph Möllers hat diese Gutachten angefertigt. Ein hoch angesehener Professor für öffentliches Recht, der sich mit Fragen der Freiheit innerhalb der demokratischen Ordnung häufig schon auseinandergesetzt hat, publizistisch immer wieder die Öffentlichkeit tritt. Also einer der ganz wichtigen Namen. Wir haben einmal von ihm einen Clip gespielt im Podcast. Erinnere ich jetzt gerade. Kann auch sein, dass wir paar gespielt haben schon mal. Einen erinnere ich besonders, als er bei Claudine Ehmke zu Gast war. Und er dann sagte, ja, in gewisser Weise findet er doch an der AfD interessant, dass die noch so sehr an die Politik glauben, dass man wirklich mit der Politik so wahnsinnig viel verändern kann.
Ich dachte, das war Blüthorn.
Nee, das war damals Christoph Möllers, der da sich in gewisser Weise amüsiert. Der freut, sagt er natürlich, kein AfD-Anhänger ist ganz im Gegenteil. Aber der sagt, es ist ja interessant, dass da noch welche auftreten, auch Wähler. Dann da sind die, die glauben, ja, wenn gerade die andere Politik, dann wird sich alles ändern. Darum geht es aber jetzt nicht um die Politik und Rechtsdruck oder so, sondern es geht tatsächlich um die Kunstfreiheit. Die wird ja hoch geschätzt im Land. Meinungsfreiheit, Kunstfreiheit, auch die Frage braucht man eigentlich beides. Wenn man die Meinungsfreiheit hat, ist da nicht die Kunst mit inkludiert. Na ja, wie ist es aber dann mit Figurenrede, könnte man ja fragen, wenn die das eine oder das andere sagen, ist das auch dann einfach Meinungsfreiheit. Na ja, was in Anführungszeichen steht, könnte ja auch nochmal anders bewertet werden. Das heißt, wir sind also in einem erst mal schon gar nicht so einfachen Gebiet. Besonders schwierig wird es aber jetzt so, dadurch, dass wir ja in der Vergangenheit der Ampelregierung, vor allem aber auch der jetzigen Regierung erleben, dass dann gesagt wird, so etwas wie die Documenta 15 darf sich nicht wiederholen. Also, dass dort Werke ausgestellt wurden, von denen manche als antisemitisch eingestuft wurden, von manchen. Ja, also auch da ist man natürlich wieder bei der Frage, ist es so oder nicht? Ich würde bei einigen Werken sagen, sie sind antisemitisch.
Da war die Meinung dann doch einhellig. Also wir sind schon viel näher dran als...
Ja, also bei einigen der Werke war tatsächlich das so. Aber wie geht man dann damit um? Was darf also der Staat machen? Er kann sich vielleicht distanzieren, ja. Aber inwieweit darf er eingreifen und wann beschränkt er damit die Kunstfreiheit? Denn die Sache ist ja so, dass auch die Kunstfreiheit, wenn jetzt nicht Volksverhetzung stattfindet, zum Beispiel ja auch antisemitische Kunst in gewisser Weise schützt. Ja, also auch das ist ja interessant, auf wie weit die Meinungsfreiheit in Deutschland geht, ist ja immer wieder erstaunlich nochmal festzuhalten. Das heißt aber, es gibt ja doch was anderes, wie wenn der Staat plötzlich diese Kunst unterstützt, weil der Staat sich ja zugleich verpflichtet hat mit dem Grundgesetz, dass er gegen Antisemitismus und gegen Rassismus ist. Also er kann ja nicht zum einen antisemitische Kunst fördern und zum anderen sagen, er wendet sich dezidiert gegen Antisemitismus, bekämpft diesen.
Die heutige Episode wird präsentiert von Surfshark. Wieder gilt, dass ich Surfshark selbst nutze und es euch daher auch gerne empfehle. Vielleicht kennt ihr die Situation, man sitzt im Hotel, im Zug oder Café, wählt sich ins offene WLAN ein. Was die wenigsten dabei bedenken, in so einem offenen Netz ist man auf einer Bühne. Wer technisch ein bisschen Ahnung hat, die haben heute viele, und im selben Netz sitzt, kann mitlesen. Alles, Logins, Mails, Bankgeschäfte. Genau dafür gibt es Surfshark. Es legt eine verschlüsselte Verbindung zwischen mein Gerät und das Internet und tauscht meine IP gegen die eines Servers irgendwo auf der Welt. Im offenen WLAN heißt das, niemand liest mehr mit. Und im normalen Alltag läuft das Werbetracking ins Leere, denn Surfshark hat ein Feature namens CleanWeb, das Werbung, Tracker und Chartseiten direkt auf der Verbindungsebene für euch aussortiert. Praktisch ist auch, dass man den eigenen Standort virtuell verlegen kann. Damit sieht man also auch im Urlaub die Mediatheken, als wäre man zu Hause. Surfshark ist dabei mehr als ein VPN. Antivirus und Alerts gehörten dazu. Alert warnt mich, sobald meine Mail-Adresse in einem Daten-Lag auftaucht. Und das alles läuft auf beliebig vielen Geräten mit einer einzigen Lizenz.
Kurz gesagt, Surfshark ist der Tarnumhang fürs Netz. Wenn ihr es ausprobieren wollt, geht auf surfshark.com 20er und gebt den Code 20er ein. Damit bekommt ihr vier zusätzliche Monate gratis auf das Jahresabo. Plus 30 Tage Geldzurückgarantie. Nochmal surfshark.com 20er Code 20er. Der Link ist in der Episodenbeschreibung.
Jetzt bist du ja schon sehr tief drin. Ich versuch nochmal die Fragestellung, die ich hier so interessant fand. Wenn Kunst ist ein Gegenstand, kann man sich sagen, Kunst ist eine Sache, die sich nicht von alleine trägt. Kunst muss immer ein bisschen finanziert, kuratiert, vielleicht sogar beauftragt werden, wie auch immer. Manche Kunst erkennt man gar nicht, solange sie nicht wo hängt, wo typischerweise Kunst hängt. Also wir haben einen Künstler. Im besten Fall wird er kuratiert, dann hängt er in eine Ausstellung. Die Ausstellung selbst ist schon eine Organisation, in der also Menschen arbeiten, die sich darum kümmern, dass da Kunstwerke hängen. Wir haben es also hier schon mit einer Dreifaltigkeit zu tun. Jetzt kommt noch die Frage dazu, wer finanziert das? Ist es ein Gebäude, das schon staatlich finanziert ist, aber die Kunstausstellung ist dann eine unter vielen? Oder ist es ein Gebäude, das eigentlich nicht für Kunst gemacht ist, aber dann kommt plötzlich der Staat und fördert, dass man da jetzt Kunst hinhängt, wie bei der Documenta, die findet ja auch auf Plätzen statt, die typischerweise nicht für die Kunst da sind. Und dann ist noch die große Frage, spielt es eine Rolle, wer das finanziert? Wenn der Staat es finanziert, hat er dann besonders Zugriff. Wenn der Staat es nicht finanziert, ist es dann nicht trotzdem Antisemitismus, aber auch noch Kunst. Also wir haben es hier mit einem Text zu tun, der so kompliziert ist. Und na klar, medial aufgeladen durch die Vorfälle, die es gab, die natürlich über Antisemitismus-Vorwurf immer eine hohe Attraktivität haben, uns alle erreicht haben. Aber das macht es ja nicht einfacher.
Und die beiden Autoren machen es sich nicht einfach. Sie versuchen auch jetzt nicht einfach zu sagen, ihr ist die Handlungsanweisung, danach müsst ihr euch richten. Sondern sie zeigen, und man ist erstaunt, wie weit doch geht, wie sehr, also wie weit man gehen kann. Man ist doch erstaunt darüber, denn sie zeigen, der Staat kann sehr wohl sehr viel einfordern, festschreiben, muss aber dann auch darüber nachdenken, wie will er das eigentlich kontrollieren? Wer beaufsichtigt das alles? Die Frage, die die Autoren stellen werden, ist auch, ist das sinnvoll, das zu tun? Ist das verhältnismäßig, das zu tun? Aber wir können hier auch einen Text lesen, der uns sagt, die Verfassung lässt relativ viel zu, was man nicht dann als das Ende der Kunstfreiheit beschreiben kann, weil der Staat diese Möglichkeiten hat, solange er fördernd auftritt. Das bedeutet aber dann auch, dass wir hier einen Text haben, der uns sagt, die Politisierung, all dessen, was wird gefördert, wer sitzt in welchen Juries, wer bekommt welchen Preis, dass diese Politisierung vermutlich, auch wenn die Autoren es nicht empfehlen, zunehmen wird. Das heißt, über diese konkreten Fälle, und vor allem geht es ja hier um die tatsächlich dann antisemitisch einzustufenden Werke auf der Documenta, zweigen sich von dort sehr viele Linien ab, die hinführen zu einer Politisierung allgemein, sodass man sagen kann, diese Kämpfe, auch in Form von Kulturkämpfen, auch von all dem, was wir jetzt bei Wolfram Weimar ja schon erleben, werden sich eher zuspitzen. Und je mehr Reglement man jetzt eigentlich schaffen will, um dies oder das zu verhindern, wird man also immer mehr diese erbitterten Debatten haben, diese Kulturkämpfe haben. Der Staat kann da sehr weit, bzw. die Politik kann da sehr weit gehen. Man ist echt, ja, in gewisser Weise auch alarmiert durch diesen Text.
Ja, also ja, der Staat kann sehr weit gehen. Aber ich bin erstmal nicht alarmiert, sondern am Anfang habe ich dann doch gedacht, ah ja, stimmt, das ist so eine Sache, die hat man gar nicht auf dem Schirm. Denn es ist ja nicht alles nur Dokumente und Antisemitismus und der Staat hängt dann da so Bilder ab und so, sondern die Besonderheit, die hier beschrieben wird für die Kunst, ist, dass wir eine Kunstlandschaft haben, die in der Bundesrepublik maßgeblich von staatlich eingerichteten Akteuren und Institutionen geprägt und durch öffentliche Mittel finanziert ist. Was jetzt bedeutet, so wie wir jetzt auch schon die Einflugsschneise gefunden haben, über, da darf der Staat da eingreifen, wie ist das Verhältnis und so. Zentral in diesem Text, finde ich, ist auch der Umstand und den kennen wir so sonst nicht, dass der Staat hier nicht unter, ich greife mal ein, um Gefahren abzuwenden oder Gesetze auch immer durchzubreiten, sondern der Staat kommt in eine besondere Rolle, da er relativ viel Freiheit für Künstler überhaupt erst selbst erschafft. Dadurch, dass sehr viele Einrichtungen einfach in staatliche Obhut sind. Sei es, dass eine Liegenschaft gegeben wird, sei es, dass eine Genehmigung erteilt wird, ja, dürfte jetzt ja Pop-Up-Kino machen oder so auf der Baustelle, sei es, dass direkt finanziert wird. Und dadurch ist der Staat in einer Rolle, die sich nicht einfach ableiten lässt aus anderen juristischen Regionen, weil hier nicht so sehr das Verbot, sondern mehr die Ermöglichung im Raum steht.
Und was ist, wenn die Ermöglichung nicht mehr gegeben wird?
Genau. Wir haben verfassungsrechtlich da gar kein... Ich erinnere daran, dass wir einmal, ich habe es schon mal reportiert, im Städte die Kultusministerin aus Baden-Württemberg hatten, die meinte, da kommen halt so Anträge von verschiedenen Häusern. Hier in Frankfurt wäre das das Städtel, das würde dann bei uns in Wiesbaden in dem Falle vorstellig werden. Und dann entscheide ich mit dem Ministerpräsidenten, wie viel Geld es gibt. Zwei Leute. So, jetzt ist natürlich zum einen die Gefahr, was ist, wenn die AfD und so, aber das ist ja auch schon ohne AfD einfach so eine Gemengelagerung. Ich denke, okay, die beiden entscheiden jetzt über die Freiheitsräume der Kunst. Denn wenn die sie nicht geben, gibt sie nicht. Aber sie wurden ja da nicht weggenommen, sondern sozusagen nicht gegeben. Und da gibt es gar keine verfassungsrechtliche Übung, wie man das als Kampfplatz versteht. Weil, wenn der Staat das nicht finanziert, ist halt nichts.
Und man kann dann verfassungsrechtlich gesehen nicht von Zensur sprechen. Denn es wird ja einfach Mittel nicht gegeben. Das heißt, etwas wird nicht ermöglicht, aber es wird ja was anderes dafür ermöglicht. Es wird nicht eine Zensur vollzogen. Man kann natürlich jetzt umgangssprachlich trotzdem sagen, es gibt so etwas wie Zensur durch Mittelentzug. Offenbar gibt es, damit ausgedrückt, wenn ich so was sagen würde, meine ich, es gibt also politische Ideen, Ideologien, die durchgesetzt werden und die dann die eine Kunst ermöglichen, die andere verunmöglichen. Der Punkt ist aber, wie du sagst, da heißt es dann, der Staat, der Leistungen gewährt, auf die im Grundsatz kein individueller Anspruch besteht, sieht sich selten gerichtlich auszufechten, den Verteilungskonflikten ausgesetzt. Empfangende haben daran kein Interesse, andere Wettbewerber darauf keinen Anspruch. Das heißt, wenn nun jetzt zum Beispiel der Kultursommer Rheinland-Pfalz ist und dort ganz viele Bewerbungen eingehen, welche Projekte gefördert werden sollten, dann gibt es eine Auswahl, die, die nicht gefördert werden, haben keinen Anspruch darauf, zu sagen, ich muss aber gefördert werden, das ist jetzt Zensur. Jetzt als ganz einfaches Beispiel genannt. Und das bringt natürlich die Schwierigkeit mit sich, dass man auch darüber nachdenken muss. Wenn man also für die Kunstfreiheit ist, kann man sich dann ständig nur auf den Staat, sollte man sich die ganze Zeit auf den Staat und damit auf die dann gerade herrschenden Politik verlassen. Für mich ist das auch, auch wenn das gar nicht da thematisiert wird, noch mal ein Text, der darüber fragen lässt, inwieweit kann man noch mal andere finanzielle Spielräume schaffen. Und da kommt das Metsenatentum vor, aber vielleicht auch ein anderes crowdfinanziertes Modell, um andere Kunst möglich zu machen, die dann nicht in dieser Weise politisch abgesegnet werden muss. Aber hier bleiben wir jetzt erstmal bei diesem staatlichen Thema, bei dem sich dann aber auch ganz klar zeigt, der politische Diskurs ist unglaublich dumm. Gerade wenn Politiker zum Beispiel sagen, so etwas wie die Berlinale darf sich nicht wiederholen. Wenn da Preisträger auf der Bühne stehen und dann sagen, es gibt gerade ein Genozid und Deutschland unterstützt Israel bei dem Genozid. Dafür irgendjemanden zur Verantwortung zu ziehen, also zu sagen, die Leiterin ist schuld oder der Kulturminister, der die Leiterin beauftragt hat oder so, ist vollkommen nach Unsinn. Denn so eine Leiterin, die hat natürlich dann eine Verantwortung gegenüber dem, was sie da auswählt und auch Personen. Aber sie kann nicht schon vorher eigentlich klar bestimmen, was werden die im Falle eines Falles auf irgendeiner Bühne öffentlich sagen. Das heißt, wenn der politische Diskurs so alarmistisch, wie er gerade ist, geführt wird, dann wird es sehr dumm. Und deswegen bin ich froh, dass wir hier so ein sachlich ruhiges, sehr difficiles Buch haben, das ein bisschen Klarheit oder viel Klarheit in eine doch sehr komische Gemengelage bringt.
Du sagst jetzt Klarheit, wir gehen jetzt natürlich gleich durch. Kapitelweise wäre meine Präferenz, weil er ist ja doch immer sehr zugeschnitten. Aber ich erinnere daran, dass wir mal zum Thema, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, irgendwas Leben und Tod, Gewissensfragen, ach ja, Verjährung von Mord und so weiter. Und dann war die Frage der Deutschlandfunk-Journalistin an den Juristen, wie ist das der Öffentlichkeit zu vermitteln? Und er sagte gar nicht. Und hier gibt es einige Textstellen, die darauf hinweisen, Kunstfreiheit auch für klar antisemitische Kunst. Ist das zu der Öffentlichkeit zu vermitteln? Nein, gar nicht. Dass etwas auf Festivals passiert und es eine Festivalleitung gibt und man sie aber freisprechen muss davon, was da passiert, weil nämlich der Einzelne auch Rechte hat, um auf einer Bühne einfach eine Dankesrede zu sagen, was er sagen will. Das ist, wie wir jetzt gesehen haben, also mir wäre das zu vermitteln, aber sehr vielen Teilen der Öffentlichkeit nicht.
Und leider vielen Politikern auch nicht.
Und vielen Politikern auch nicht, genau. Und so schreiben sie hier auch ganz klar, das klassische Verständnis der Grundrechte als Abwehrrechte, die ja relativ häufig nicht gegeben sind, wenn es darum geht, dass der Staat ja was ermöglichen soll, dass, wenn er es nicht tut, einfach eine Duldung von nichts ist. Und damit sind wir schon auf ganz schönem Gelände. Also das klassische Verständnis der Grundrechte als Abwehrrechte gegen staatliche Interventionen stößt in diesem Dreieck von der Staat, die Kulturinstitution und die Künstlerin schnell an seine Grenzen. Also auch bei der Frage, wie mächtig ist der Staat? Wenn wir jetzt die Kunst wieder als Zivilgesellschaft daneben stellen und wir dann wieder sagen, der Staat ist so super mächtig, der kann so viel und so, aber hier wird dann doch relativ viel Freiheit auch den Künstlern gewährt. Die Klammer ist nur, sie brauchen halt Geld und Räume. Das ist das Ding. Und damit sind wir aber eben nicht bei Abwehrrechten der Staat, die Polizei darf reinreiten und irgendwas machen und so, sondern da sind wir einfach bei wirtschaftlichen Fragen. Wenn das alles mit Zehntum wäre, das Städte will jetzt sicher zur Umstellung auf Stiftung, jeder darf so mit Geld reinstiften, um auch eine dauerhafte, auch finanzielle, staatsferne Finanzierung herzustellen.
Frankfurt hat ja eh eine sehr finanzkräftige und aber auch kunstliebende Bürgerschaft, wo das ja eine lange Tradition hat. Das ist ja eher die Ausnahme, wenn man sich das für die Bundesrepublik ansieht. Aber das ist auch ein Punkt, den ich aus dem Buch mitnehme. Man muss über das Ökonomische sehr sprechen, wenn man über Freiheit sprechen will. Das gilt nicht nur für uns alle, wenn wir sagen, ja, wir sind natürlich frei, aber sind wir auch wirklich im Sinne von ökonomischen Unabhängigkeit, weil diese ökonomische Unabhängigkeit, die wir jetzt zum Beispiel haben, wir müssen jetzt nicht reportieren und hoffen, dass Friede Springer noch einverstanden ist mit uns, sonst lässt sie uns. Diese ökonomische Freiheit bringt es natürlich, damit sich, dass man sich auch, was die Meinungsfreiheit anbelangt, viel mehr rausnehmen kann. Denn da ist der Staat dann eher nicht gleich zu befürchten, sondern eher, dass ökonomische Repression kommt. Das war ja auch was, was wir bei der Meinungsfreiheit hatten, bei dem Buch von Precht, dass er sagte, wenn die Kosten hoch werden, die Meinung zu äußern, dann wird es ein Problem. Und hier reden wir eigentlich auch sehr viel über Kosten. Also müssen wir über das Ökonomische bei der Kunstfreiheit auch sprechen. Öffentliche Kunstfreiheit von Christoph Möllers und Nils Weinberg. Das ist also das Buch, das wir jetzt im Salon ganz ausführlich miteinander diskutieren. Wer das hören will, kann den Salon abonnieren. Möglich ist das über Steady, Apple und Patreon. Außerdem gibt es dann noch Literatur-Tipps von uns. Und wir sprechen natürlich auch über Gegenmacht von Arne Semsrott.